maurice leblanc 71 ans était dans un
état de santé précaire le 5 juin dernier
le puy 23 jours il était dans le coma
mon mari était assez faible le mandat
d'une minute lui tétreault séjourna des
travaux sont prévus dans l'ancienne
urgences de l'hôpital charles lemoyne à
longueuil le circuit d'oxygène est
rompue accidentellement
neuf patients de l'unité de soins
intensifs qu'ovide manque d'air les
infirmières et les inhalothérapeutes se
sont rapidement mobilisés et maurice
leblanc n'a pas survécu pour nous ça
clique comme un soulagement mais ça le
pain et la peine
il ya des soirs comme elsa me ferais ça
déçoit que je trouve ça très fine et le
sis de la montérégie centre confirme
qu'une mauvaise interprétation d'un plan
est à l'origine de l'accident
on a omis de réaliser quand pas
d'oxygène un endroit couper l'oxygène
dans une section des soins intensifs où
il y avait les patients coville lors
d'une erreur humaine est humaine comme
on dit en droit de l'aviation ou à
d'autres droits générale illimitée à
conjointe de maurice leblanc n'en veux
pas aux personnes à la source de cette
méprise qui a coûté la vie à son mari
les acides et tout le monde peut en
faire on les accepte on les refuse
- je les accepte pas ça vaut bien ça
bien fini ouais ça a bien fini pour moi
mais c'est pas plus facile
malheureusement le sifflement de
puissants on a des problèmes avec le
système intelligent
cette affaire survient alors que deux
femmes sont mortes dans les dernières
semaines à l'hôpital charles lemoyne
dans des circonstances troubles qui
devront être éclaircies par des enquêtes
actuellement en cours il si mélissa
françois radio canada montréal